voilà un défilé d'un bus qian maintenu
auprès du bateau c'est aussi comme quoi
on ne savait pas
dans tes mains ce qu'ils ont été
alors semble-t-il semble attirer deux
sens hier pourrait couper les résultats
sans blague il ya tellement de bruit
il ne sait pas où tallinn
je ne sais plus où me wade informations
mesdames et messieurs votre attention
s'il vous plaît nous vous informons que
tous les résidents de la martinique
débarqueront ici à fort de france et que
le pape se dirigera par la suite en
guadeloupe
ainsi tous les visiteurs de la
martinique passagers actuels du navire
seront confinés quinze jours soit à
domicile ou de manière collective par
conséquent personne n'est autorisé à
quitter le navire
si le questionnaire que nous vous
remettrons n'est pas correctement rempli
à savoir que tous doivent remplir un
questionnaire par personne y compris les
personnes et donc les bébés soient
rassurés que tout sera pris en charge
par l'organisme de la santé etc à votre
sortie des bus
vous attendrez vous entendrez par la
suite des opérations
veuillez donc avoir beauval isambert l'a
senti se déroulera de la manière
suivante les premiers à descendre seront
donc tous ceux qui ont été mis dans les
registres du médecin de bord les seconds
à descendre seront les personnes
fragiles à mobilité réduite et les
familles avec des petits enfants par la
suite sortiront toutes les personnes
restantes
nous vous remercions de votre
compréhension et nous vous souhaitons un
bon retour dans le ring